ALFRED SPECTOR: So welcome
to all of you.
My name is Alfred Specter.
I'm head of research at Google,
and I do some other
things as well.
In particular, I've met some of
you that have been part of
our intern program, and that's
something that I have the
great pleasure of leading
within Google.
I've had a diverse background,
like many of us, doing a bunch
of different things, but I was
an academic for a while, and
I've been in business, and an
entrepreneur, et cetera.
In this session, we're going
to talk about a few things.
First, we're going to talk about
our approach to research
and engineering, because I think
it's something which
should be of interest to you at
Google IO, because I think
it's the thing that will keep
us on the cutting edge and
really keep the kind of sessions
that you've heard
about, say, in the keynotes
yesterday morning, going.
Second, I want to just talk a
little bit about how we relate
to the world of research and
innovation outside of Google.
Most of you are part of that
world, and you're essential to
what we're trying to do.
Third thing is, as a panel,
we'll talk about things that
are of interest to us.
What we're working on,
and what are our
views of the future?
At the end, let me just
mention it now--
there will be a survey.
Please fill it out.
We are requested by the powers
that be to ask you to do that,
and we would indeed
like you to do it.
On the panel, and you can see
in front, on your right is
Thad Starner, who is at Google,
and also a professor
of computing at Georgia Tech.
He is the TLM-- the technical
lead manager--
of Google Glass.
So you can imagine kinds
of things that he'll be
interested in talking
with you about.
Computer vision, virtual
reality, machine learning,
image and video and the like.
Next to Thad in the gray shirt
is Peter Norvig, who is our
director of research here
in Mountain View.
He headed search quality at
Google at one time, in the
very early days of Google.
He's an acknowledged leader in
artificial intelligence, has
co-written the most
popular book.
Also, he created, with Sebastian
Thrun, the AI course
which got MOOCs going.
How many of you took Peter's
AI course in the room?
So you all know Peter
very well--
or not all of you, but--
Ah, Peter recognizes you all.
Yes indeed.
And then on your left is Jeff
Dean, who's a Google fellow.
He's been at Google for
quite a while--
was involved the earliest
days of implementing our
advertising systems, and has
been, really, a pillar of
strength and of creativity in
creating the distributed
computing infrastructure at
Google with Sanjay Ghemawat.
They invented MapReduce.
And he's a member of the
National Academy of
Engineering.
And recently, Sanjay and Jeff
won the ACM Infosys Foundation
Software Systems Award.
I think that was the research
systems innovation of the
decade 2000 to 2010.
That's my view.
And we can hear about what Jeff
is currently working on--
MapReduce 2 or 3,
or I don't know.
We'll find out when he talks.
So just to start, as I think
about research at Google, the
most interesting thing for me
is that if we think of the
Google mission statement
to organize the world's
information and make it
universally accessible and
useful, it's basically a candy
store for computer scientists
and related disciplines.
Statistics and mathematics and
related aspects of engineering
and the like.
There's so many problems in our
field that are included
within that, and understanding,
and building
very large scale systems, and
security, and user experience,
dot dot dot.
So virtually every problem in
the field is subsumed within
that mission statement, and
we get to go work on it.
So that's sort of the really fun
part of being at Google.
The second thing that I think
makes Google research
interesting is that we blur
the boundaries between
research and engineering.
And why is that?
Why don't we believe that we
should have some number of
people isolated in a
room somewhere-- a
very nice room, maybe--
thinking great thoughts,
inventing the future.
And then we'll go tell the
engineers what to go do.
We don't believe that for
a number of reasons.
One reason is that building
systems--
building large scale systems--
requires every bit as much
creativity as a new idea on
how to go do something.
So there isn't a differential
in terms of creativity, in
terms of hard work,
intelligence, et cetera,
oftentimes in building something
in a way that's
really valuable and useful, and
in thinking of the idea.
A second reason, I think, is
that our field, computer
science, and of course, the
engineering related fields as
well, is increasingly an
engineering discipline, not
just a mathematical discipline,
and also
increasingly a field
which is empirical.
So our field, initially, if you
think about it and go back
to the earliest days, it
was very significantly
mathematical-- the work of
Turing, mathematician, really.
A lot of von Neumann's work
was mathematical.
There was ever increasing
engineering as we built
fancier and fancier hardware
devices and software stacks
and the like.
So engineering became a
big part of the field.
And then in the last
10 to 20 years--
really since the advent
of machine learning--
it's become an empirical
discipline, which means access
to large scale data, lots of
usage, and large scale is
really important to the field.
So now there's a tripod
under the field.
So if you separate research from
all the data in usage,
you skip a lot of the
engineering, and particularly,
you skip the empirical
nature of the field.
So we think you can't do that,
and that has motivated or kind
of blurred the boundaries
between research and
engineering approach.
Slav Petrov, Peter Norvig, and
I wrote a paper in the
communications of the ACM last
summer called Google's Hybrid
Approach to Research where we
made these arguments as
clearly as we know how.
So what it leads to is a
situation where we are we
organize, what I would say,
opportunistically, in whatever
way makes the most sense to
accomplish something.
So sometimes it makes sense.
We have a very goal driven
effort that's product driven,
like, say, Google Glass.
There's an awful lot of research
that's needed that in
order to make that really work
right, but it makes sense to
let that go off and
do its thing.
Google X does that, and to think
about it as part of a
goal directed activity to
produce Google Glass.
Sometimes it's a technology
based effort.
Sometimes we don't have
a specific goal.
We want to improve
a technology.
And sometimes we do that in
conjunction with existing
systems, when we want to
improve, say, recommendation
algorithms in something
that we're doing.
Or it may be something
that's new.
We have a better way of doing
OCR, and we think we do, and
we have a separate team that's
separate from the engineering
team to a large degree, because
we think we have a
better approach to optical
character recognition.
So we organize in whatever way
makes sense, and we all work
for the same company,
and there's an
enormous amount of fluidity.
Part of the reason it works is
that we treat engineering with
enormous respect across the
whole business, as I said
earlier, and we feel that our
engineering team is enormously
talented and capable of whatever
classes of challenges
that we have, whether invention
of new things or
making things work.
Last thing I would say about
Google research-- and to those
of you that are researchers, I
hope this isn't problematic--
we view that good research is
defined by impact, not by
publication.
So publication is a
part of impact.
A good publication is extremely
important, so we
certainly endorse that.
So we endorse peer reviewed
publications that are cited by
lots of people that change
the nature of the field.
It's an excellent way of
information dissemination.
But in this day and age, unlike
the day and age of,
say, Sir Isaac Newton and the
Royal Society when this
started, it's a different
world.
There are other ways of
disseminating information.
So open source.
I would argue that the Android
open source release or the
Chromium open source release
are fantastically valuable
publications which teach an
enormous amount of the world.
Indeed, standards are
publications that codify the
best practices.
And they're also, of course,
extremely useful.
And indeed, our products and
other people's products also
are forms of publication and
engineering discipline,
because they push the state of
the art, and they declare a
state of the art.
And usually people sort of
understand why they work, and
that indeed sets a new level
underneath the field.
So we all try to achieve
impact, and we measure
ourselves based on impact,
inclusive of papers, but other
things as well.
By no means do we do everything
ourselves.
We strongly support and
work with universities
on a regular basis.
It's not coincidental that--
I mean, it's not like the only
person that feels he's part of
a university, as well at
Google with Thad here.
There are many people that have
lots of university ties
in one way, shape, or
form at Google.
We fund about a couple hundred
research grants a year at
universities.
We have the 1 to 2,000 technical
interns at Google
every summer from universities,
and we fund
fellowships around the world.
It's really important to us that
the university community
be really healthy, inventing
new things, and of course,
training lots of students.
The open source world is also
extremely important to us.
So we are large supporters
of open source.
Large amounts of the code that
we use are based on it, and we
contribute large amounts of code
to the open source world.
One of our most innovative
programs there combines
education and open source.
It's the Summer of
Code program.
Any of you know about this?
Google Summer of Code?
So there, we support large
numbers, usually of fairly
young students in the summer--
1,000 to 1,500--
that work on open
source projects.
And we think it's a good way
to contribute to their
education, and to keep that
community going along as well.
And of course, then, there's
the developer ecosystem.
Developers are doing, in many
ways, the most advanced work
with platforms and technologies
that Google has,
and we recognize the enormous
value that you engender for
our users, and that reflects
on what we do as well.
All in all, the track record's
been pretty good.
We've done a lot of
innovative things.
A lot of what you heard about
yesterday morning in terms of
being able to combine
information and to do valuable
in speech recognition and
natural language processing
and understanding--
all those things come out of
research projects initially,
at Google and elsewhere.
If you look at all the beautiful
image processing,
the sort of automation and image
processing, that's image
processing work that is grounded
in some of the best
research that we know.
And I could go on, but I'd be
talking too long, then.
So what I'd like to do is to
come down and join the panel
for a while while they talk
about some things that are on
their mind, and then we'll take
questions, all right?
So Jeff, why don't
you go first?
What's on your mind?
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
Is this on?
Can you hear me?
OK.
So I guess I'll just tell
you what I've been
working on most recently.
I've been working on a large
scale distributed machine
learning system that essentially
is trying to use
biologically inspired neural
networks to solve a number of
difficult problems in speech
recognition, vision, computer
vision, and natural language
processing.
Essentially, the idea is that
you take large amounts of
data, and you try to
automatically infer higher and
higher levels of abstraction.
Rather than hand engineering
features and then trying to do
fairly shallow machine learning
kinds of techniques,
instead, we start with the raw
data, and by using very large
amounts of data and
computational power, we can
have the system automatically
learn what are important
patterns to extract
out of data.
There was a New York Times
article about some of our
vision work on automatically
recognizing cats.
I don't know how many
of you saw that.
But essentially, the idea is we
never told the system what
a cat was, and we built a system
where at least one of
the neurons in the system was
very selective for whether or
not it contained a cat.
That's not that useful in and
of itself, but it turns out
the vision system that you can
build, when you pre-train it
with this kind of thing,
is actually quite
state of the art.
And we've also been applying
this to speech recognition.
So we've been collaborating with
a speech team to deploy
deep neural nets as the acoustic
modeling portion of
our speech recognition systems,
and that's given very
significant reductions
in [INAUDIBLE] rate.
And then we're looking at
interesting representations of
text, where you represent words
in very high dimensional
spaces, so that similar words
are close together in a 1,000
dimensional space or something,
and that seems like
a pretty important and powerful
way of reasoning
about text.
PETER NORVIG: OK.
My main efforts lately have
been in online education.
We built a open source system
for creating classes.
We just had the fourth release
last week, but I won't say
anything more about that,
because right after this
session, in this room, I'm
going to talk about it in
another session.
So stick in your seats if you
want to hear about that.
Instead, I'll talk about
something just because
yesterday I was talking with
one of the team members who
was so excited that they had
their launch here at IO of the
music recommendation system.
And this, in some ways, is
similar to the type of thing
Jeff was talking about,
that it's a
machine learning system.
And I think maybe the main point
isn't that it was music,
because we didn't really have
that many experts on music.
We had people who like music.
But the exciting thing is that
we have a process for doing
that type of learning.
So we start to say, well,
what do we have?
Well, we've got the raw files.
They've got sound waves, we've
got the four-year transform of
those sound waves, and that
gives us some input.
Then we have the metadata.
We have what's the title, the
artist, and so on, the genre
of the music that's sort of
associated with that track,
and we have the meta metadata
of everything that's been
written on the web about
those artists.
And then we have the social data
of people who like this
one also like that one.
And from that, and from the
processes that we built up
saying we know how to gather a
lot of data, we know how to
store it, we know how to process
it in a distributed
fashion, and we know some
mechanisms for building
machine learning systems,
we were able to
come up with something.
And I've been pretty
happy with it.
I've been playing with it and
comparing it to other
recommendation systems, and
for me, it does better.
Maybe I like weird
kinds of music.
But it does a great job, and
it's just a demonstration of
how far you can get by applying
this methodology of
learning from data.
THAD STARNER: So I'll tell you
guys what I'm most passionate
about right now.
Let me ask a question
of the audience.
How many of you actually know
sign language, or a little bit
of sign language?
Wow, very good.
Anybody good enough to actually
translate what I'm saying?
No?
So 95% of deaf children are born
to hearing parents, and
most of those hearing parents
will never learn sign language
well enough to teach it
to their children.
What happens is, as an
infant, you actually
gain short term memory.
You learn short term memory
through the process of
learning language.
And so the deaf children I work
with get neither access
to English, because they can't
hear, or sign language,
because their parents don't
learn sign, until they get to
kindergarten.
And that means that while you
and I might be able to
remember five digits, like,
say, 45156, the children I
work with can remember
two digits.
And that affects them
for the rest of
their life, most often.
It's a barrier for education,
it's a barrier for jobs, it's
a barrier for life.
So what we're trying to do is
create applications that help
hearing parents of deaf infants
learn how to sign.
We have an application you'll
see coming out later on
Android on the Play that
is called Smart Sign.
It allows parents to get
lessons in little
microinteractions throughout
the day where they'll get a
new sign that is shown to them
on their cell phone.
Right now, I have a sign
linguist who works with me at
Georgia Tech.
He's betting that it's going to
be even better with glass.
He wants to have pop up little
sign language lessons
throughout your day, depending
on what context you're in.
You also, if you're working with
an older child, and you
don't know what sign that you
need, you can actually say,
OK, Glass, what is the
sign for horse?
And it shows it to you
in your eye piece.
So that way, you can actually
use the sign while you're in
conversation with your child.
Another thing we're doing is
making a game that helps these
deaf children acquire language
skills, and we're actually
using computer vision to track
the hands and actually verify
that they're signing the right
thing to progress in the game.
It's called Copycat.
If you go to YouTube and look
for my name and Copycat and
Smart Sign, you'll find
these applications.
And hopefully, what we can do
is actually get these things
out there, get them publicly
available, so that more
hearing parents can more easily
learn sign language,
and more of these deaf children
can actually acquire
the memory span and the word
span that we would like to see
in their normal education.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Great.
I'm going to go up and act
as moderator in a minute.
But before I do that, I'll just
mention one thing that's
been on my mind, and even a
bet with one of the senior
vice presidents that
I have on this.
And one of the questions is,
to what extent do we really
have all the tools today to do
extremely deep artificial
intelligence?
So the question that I think
about a lot is, we have the
Knowledge Graph, we have the
ability to parse natural
language, we have neural network
technology, we have
enormous opportunities to gain
feedback from users as to
whether things that we do are
right, pleasing, or not right,
or not pleasing.
If we combine all of these
things together, with humans
in the loop, continually
providing feedback, do our
systems become, really, in
all way intelligent?
Is that sufficient?
And you could call that the
combination hypothesis,
something I have been calling
it for a decade, that as we
combine all of these different
things together, different
technologies that years ago, AI
people would've fought and
said, that's not important.
We don't need that.
We'll just do this.
I think we need them all.
And if we do them all, will
that yield what we want?
We'll be able to take an image
and write a textual
explanation of what that
image is about.
Not just, there's a face, and
there's the Empire State
Building, or whatever.
But can we describe what
we humans would
say about that image?
When we do a summarization of
a paragraph, can we not just
be sort of heuristically clever
and pull out a few
subjects and objects, but
can we really get the
right tenor of it?
Can we actually get
the negations
correctly, et cetera?
It's a good question.
It'll be very interesting
to see how far we go.
What I feel today about that is,
we have an enormous amount
of runway to push this.
So I think the kinds of
demonstrations you saw in the
morning when you talk to your
machine and it tells you
things you want to know--
I think they're going
to go really far.
But how far, we don't
know, I think.
And I think that's one of the
really interesting open
questions that we, and I hope
all of you in the research
world, are looking at as well.
So let me turn to a different
role here, and I will play
moderator as best as I can.
All right.
What's the distinction between
research within the research
group and research within
the rest of the company?
Peter, why don't you
take that one here?
You've been doing research and
being in the company and
everything for longer
than I have.
PETER NORVIG: I guess we try not
to make a big distinction.
We do have a separate research
group, but whether you're in
research or in engineering is
more driven by what area
you're working on than by how
researchy you are, and whether
you were a professor, or how
many papers you want to write,
and those kinds of things.
So when I was running search
quality, that was in the
engineering organization,
and so everybody I
hired was an engineer.
And it didn't matter how
many PhDs they had.
If you're working on
an engineering
project, you're an engineer.
If you're doing something that
we aren't doing yet, then we
can call you a research
scientist.
ALFRED SPECTOR: I think that
probably answers that one.
I'm going to click yes.
Where can we read and/or learn
about current non-secret
Google research projects?
Non-secret.
Well, that's good, because if
they're secret, I think we
know the answer to that.
Jeff, do you want
to try that one?
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
So on research.google.com,
there's actually a link to
recent publications that people
have made, categorized
into a whole bunch of
different areas.
So that's one way.
People at Google often give
external talks that are
videotaped, so you can find
those on the web about less
fully developed work that's
not quite ready for
publication.
I think going to conferences
is another good way.
We often publish papers there,
chat with people informally at
conferences, sort of the normal
way that the research
community collaborates.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Right.
And indeed, there is a G+ Google
research group that you
can subscribe to, and that's
also something that--
Research at Google is what it's
called, I believe, right?
So you should subscribe to
that as well, and I think
you'll see a lot of what
we're doing there.
Let's see.
The next question is, Google
is hard to approach
externally, both for figuring
out who is working on a
specific problem, and for
knowing what you're getting
into when you apply for a job.
How should academics
form successful
interactions with Google?
All the team members here are
looking at me on this one.
I guess I don't get to delegate
this one here.
So it's a fine question.
I mean, we are either happily or
regrettably a big company.
Lou Gerstner once said, every
little company wants to be
big, and every big company
wants to be little.
There's some truth in
that statement.
So it would be nice if we were
little, and then you'd know
who to talk to, because there
are only 10 of us.
I think that the best approach
is actually to find someone
you know at Google
and talk to them.
I'm guessing that most of you
know somebody at the company,
and I would try to vector
through them to find someone.
I think this is still
a personal world.
We're all humans.
We talk.
We send email, and chat,
and such things.
I think that's really
a very good
approach for doing things.
But then you could also vector
off of the various things that
we have on our websites and
find out from there.
So I think that's probably
the best approach.
Maybe we need to build
a system for this or
something like this.
I don't know.
All right, let's see.
Is a Ph.D. Degree a must for
doing research at Google?
Can external people contribute
in some way even without
joining the team?
Anyone want to take that one?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah, I guess
I could take it.
So I think a Ph.D. Is indicative
of the kind of
person that we like to hire--
a person who's shown that they
have a passionate interest,
and that they can carry through
work over the period
of many years, and come up with
something successful.
And so getting a Ph.D. Is a good
way to demonstrate you're
that kind of person.
But if you can demonstrate
it some other way,
that's just as good.
We don't really care if
you have the degree.
We care what type of
person you are.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Right.
Absolutely.
THAD STARNER: I'll
add to that.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Great.
THAD STARNER: Again, as Alfred
was saying, there's not much
distinction between engineering
and research, and
oftentimes, some of the best
research is people
transitioning from engineering
into doing something with the
research teams, and they
can come from any level
background.
It's more about being able to
do the work and having the
intellectual curiosity and
discipline to do it.
JEFF DEAN: I'll even
add something.
One thing I find, even in my own
work, is that I go through
cycles of working on a very
exploratory thing where I'm
doing more research, and then
as that sort of comes to
fruition, hopefully I'll bring
it closer to actually building
a real product out of it.
And that sort of shifts what I
do to more of an engineering
thing, where I know what
needs to be done.
And then when that's sort of at
a good spot, then I go back
and find some more researchy
thing to do.
And so even individual
people kind of cycle
through this continuum.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Right.
Can external people contribute
some way even
without joining the team?
The answer is, we have quite a
few collaborations going on
externally with folks.
It often works well when open
source platforms are the
basis, because then intellectual
property issues
don't get in the way.
But there's an awful lot
of that at Google.
We do an awful lot in the
open source community.
So I think so.
When there's deep IP involved,
then that's always
challenging, and there's just,
I'm afraid, no way around it.
But we do, in fact, collaborate
with thousands and
thousands of people through our
open source platforms that
either we lead on or that others
lead on and that we
contribute to.
All right, who is
our Steve Jobs?
And who picks who--
this looks like who singular
picks the big ideas, or is it
distributed?
Jeff, you want to
try that one?
Or maybe everyone should
answer that.
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
I mean, I think it's a
combination of things.
One is a lot of times, new ideas
come from someone just
tinkering on their own and
exploring some new thing that
they think Google should
be doing, and
that we're not currently.
And a lot of times, those sort
of prototypes or ideas become
full fledged projects that
really push the company
forward in some area.
And other times, Larry or Sergei
will say, why aren't we
doing this?
And then that will sort
of form a team.
It's a combination of these
things, and great new ideas
come from all over, so it's not
like we wait until Larry
says we should do this.
But if he does say that, he's
often right, and you should
pay attention.
ALFRED SPECTOR: I think
generally our strength is
actually that we're
distributed, to a large extent.
Certainly, and you heard Larry
yesterday, he's encouraging
big things.
So we are possessing a CEO now,
and with Eric as well,
that has encouraged really
significant results that
benefit lots and lots of
users in the world.
So he's always done that.
He's always pushed for
discontinuities.
So that's a big role
that he plays.
But Larry can't do everything
himself.
He'd be the first to
tell you that.
So he depends on many of us to
have good ideas, and to come
up with things that
we want to go do.
And some of them arise, as Jeff
said, sort of naturally
from an existing project.
That's, I would say, probably
the most common thing that
happens is something sort of
just sort of obvious to do
next when you're doing a
project, and a lot of what we
do is undoubtedly
based on that.
All right.
Last year, Google's CFO
mentioned at an innovation
conference in Montreal that
Google's mantra is to make
sure each project is capable of
affecting one million people.
How do we balance this reach
with research and revenue
generation?
Well, I think some things start
small and grow, and I
think that's the answer.
And we don't always know which
ones will do that.
So we certainly are desirous of
doing things that are truly
impactful, and we're a
big company, so our
standards are high.
But we don't really know which
ones are going to do that, so
we start some things
that don't work.
And we don't know.
There are numerous efforts
that I'm involved in.
Some you see, some
you don't see.
And we don't know if they'll
work, which is the nature of
engineering and research.
You don't know.
You must see that in
the Glass world.
There's some things you
try, and don't--
THAD STARNER: One of the things
is, there's so many
niche things you can do with
wearable computers that aren't
going to affect a
million people.
They could be $100 million
businesses, but they're not
the big win you expect.
And you try to make the product
such that other people
go out and do that.
You try and enable it,
not close any doors.
And you try and make sure that
the academics who are
interested in accessibility
can do what they
want with the device.
People who are interested in
industrial things like repair
and inspection means that
they can do what they
want with the device.
Try not to shut anybody out.
But it also allows people to
really explore quickly, grow
quickly, and see where the big
hits are going to be, not just
at Google, but out in the
world in general.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Are there people
that would like to come
up to a microphone live?
We have audio recognition
capabilities here on stage,
and can deal with that.
So if anyone would like
to come up, feel free.
You can make your way to a
microphone while we're doing
the next question.
Could you go to the
mic please?
Because we'd love to
hear your question.
AUDIENCE: My question is, in
those days, there was a
professor by name [INAUDIBLE].
He converted the water energy
into the productive energy.
So why can't Google use the
energy which is generated in
the Bermuda Triangle to some
constructive energy?
ALFRED SPECTOR: So, I'm sorry.
So why can't we use
the energy--
AUDIENCE: Generated in the
Bermuda Triangle near the
Atlantic Ocean, you know?
And use it for some constructive
energy.
And Because those
ideas are now--
THAD STARNER: I'll take that.
ALFRED SPECTOR: OK, fine.
All right.
THAD STARNER: So one of my
specialties is energy
harvesting, particularly
for mobile devices.
But it turns out that trying
to gather environmental
energy, especially for things
like ocean power and that sort
of stuff, you can do things like
PVDF stave, that sort of
stuff, but it's very hard to
do that at any sort of
scalable level.
If you're interested in that, go
check out something called
Ocean Engineering.
It's a little company in the
little town I grew up where
they actually are looking at
these sorts of things about
generating power
from the ocean.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Another
question, yes.
AUDIENCE: My name is
Loretta Cheeks.
I'm a PhD at ASU in CS.
I have two questions.
The gentleman on the end, with
the Glass-- are you thinking
about making the Glass
accessible to the autism
community, or anyone who
need independent living
capabilities?
Because it would be a big help
for a lot of reasons.
And the next question-- do you
have a tool that's comparable
to Weka, that will allow you
to do some of the feature
extractions and data mining
type of things?
THAD STARNER: So I can take both
of those, because these
guys don't know what I'm
working on the space.
So this is another example
where we're trying to
specifically keep Glass
open for people
who in these spaces.
A good friend of mine at Georgia
Tech, Gregory Abowd,
works very much with autism,
and we're reaching out to
academics right now with Glass
to try to give them early
access to the device, and to
some of the inner guts, so
they can actually use it for
these particular things.
And you'll see Gregory using
it, not just in future.
Now, as far as the feature
extraction.
So Weka is really great for
when you have, say, you're
comparing two images together.
One of my specialties is in
time sequences, and we're
doing something called
pattern discovery.
One of the things we're looking
at right now is
looking at birdsong, and
trying to pull out the
fundamental units of birdsong.
We're looking at dolphin
vocalizations, trying to pull
out the fundamental parts of
dolphin vocalizations.
It's very hard to do, but you
can see some of that in a PhD
thesis by David Minen that
you can download
and take a look at.
And that's for time
varying signals.
And that looks for things
that are repeated.
And you try to explain time
by what's called motifs.
And if you're interested in
that, come talk to me later.
It's one of the things that
we're very much interested in.
As a matter of fact, it's why I
got into wearable computing
in the first place.
I'm trying to-- and this
is something I
should tell Alfred about.
One of the reasons I started
wearable computing was I
really wanted to make a computer
that sees as we see,
hears as we hear, tracks the
motions of our hands, and
discovers the activities of
our daily lives, learns to
string those together in the
sort of scripts and frames
standpoint, and actually learns
what it is to be human.
Not just what it is to describe
a particular image,
but actually the meaning of
it in the human world.
With that.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Thank you.
PETER NORVIG: Let
me add to that.
We do have a service called the
Prediction APIs, where you
ship us your data and we run a
suite of algorithms over it,
and we send back classifications
or
regressions.
ALFRED SPECTOR: That's a cloud
service you can find if you
type prediction API Google
or something like that.
You'll see how to use it.
And it's meant to be
quite easy to use.
It's just as Peter said.
You give it some data, you
give it some examples, we
train, and then off you go.
All right, let's see.
I think in the back was
the first question.
You.
Yes, you, sir, in
the blue shirt.
AUDIENCE: My company works
with education, so I'm
privileged to see every day the
impact the tools that you
build, the work that
you do has on
students and parents globally.
And I think it's quite profound
how the tools you
build enable social change.
I'm curious whether at Google
research you look at the
impact of social change, and
what it means, for example,
for things like collaborative
consumption.
ALFRED SPECTOR: I don't
actually know--
does everyone know the word
collaborative consumption?
I don't know that term, so could
you define that for us?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure.
There's probably experts
in the room.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Briefly, yes.
AUDIENCE: Briefly.
The idea is a lot of the tools
we build, particularly in
Silicon Valley, are geared
at consumption.
Collaborative consumption is
about building things like
communal gardens.
It's about ways of using
resources we already have in a
way that's shared.
ALFRED SPECTOR: OK, got it.
AUDIENCE: Autonomous cars,
great example.
ALFRED SPECTOR: So the way I
would put that is I think the
group that's most interested
in topics like that is
google.org's engineering team,
which is extremely interested
in how we can use technology
to be a lever to improve
governance, participation, and
democracy, to try to create
greater transparency in
government, to make energy
consumption more efficient, to
allow for grids to be more
effectively managed and
utilized, and the like.
So I think those would be the
places where we are doing work
that's most related to that
in google.org, so you
could check into that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Yes, sir,
in the orange, or red.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Peter from Toronto.
It strikes me that if any team
is capable of bringing SkyNet
online, it's this team.
My actual question is, how often
do ethical debates arise
in decision making?
THAD STARNER: First
conversation I had with Sergei.
I've been doing wearable
computing for 20 years.
Part of my daily life.
And one of the first things we
did is said, OK, here are the
things are probably going
to happen, and
let's build out slowly.
Let's have small communities
using this who can actually
get familiar with how these
devices can be used in a
socially appropriate manner,
and then let's build it out
larger and larger and
scale these things.
And so I think it comes up
routinely within Google, from
what I've seen.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah, we were able
to get down from Asimov's
three laws to one law--
don't be evil.
But it is a constant struggle to
try to interpret that, and
say, if we make a move in one
direction, are the outcomes
going to be good or not?
And to do that, you have to
look ahead many steps.
And we keep trying to do
a better job of that.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Just in my
thinking, there's an enormous
amount of distribution of
thinking about those issues
throughout Google.
So it's not that there's a group
of ethicists somewhere
that rule on things.
I think all of us as engineers
and scientists in Google think
deeply about what are the
consequences, pro and con, of
what we might do?
How can we mitigate the con
and maximize the pro?
And just speaking as a member
of the National Academy of
Engineering, those of you
who are engineers, we
should all do that.
It should be part and parcel
of our code of ethics as
engineers that we do no harm.
AUDIENCE: My name is Vajay.
So my question is, so it used
to be that Google presented
search results and relevancy
irregardless of the
individual, right?
And now there's a sense that
relevancy depends on who is
asking for it.
So the way I look at the current
way of thinking about
the Knowledge Graph and trying
to assess semantics from the
broader amount of information,
that's sort of done at the
moment, or my impression
is, done
irregardless of the person.
And I'm wondering, on the
research team, what the
philosophy is behind the balance
of how semantics are
determined based on the
individual, as opposed to the
entire corpus?
I don't know if that
makes sense.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah, I can
take this one.
I mean, I think really, you do
want personalized results.
Because if you know, for
example, that I like spicy
food, and I query for
restaurants in some new town,
it should bias those results
to my interests.
And so there's a bit of a
tension between how much do
you weigh those personal
interests for some new query
you've done or some new
information need, and what the
general populace thinks.
And I think there's a variety
of different levels at which
you do this.
You can adjust things based on
the language someone speaks.
You can adjust it based on
the country they're in.
You can adjust it based on their
current location at a
very fine grain level.
Are they standing
in downtown Palo
Alto, or in San Francisco?
That could affect things
quite significantly.
And so it's a constant not
really tension, but you're
really trying to balance all
these different factors, and a
lot of it is data driven.
So you try to understand when
you want to weigh certain
personalized factors much more
than in other circumstances.
AUDIENCE: So is that balance
something that more has to be
tweaked, or can that itself
also come [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFF DEAN: That can also
be machine learned.
So you can do a lot of machine
learning on the kinds of
actions people take.
Like, we do a lot of online
testing of different kinds of
algorithmic changes, and look
at those sorts of--
ALFRED SPECTOR: We
have to move on.
So I'm going to do a bunch of
questions very quickly, and
then we'll move this, because
we're running down to the last
four minutes, and I think we
need to stay on schedule here.
One question is, we do open
source on some projects and
publish papers.
Is there a rule of thumb for
what we release as open source
and what remains proprietary
code?
I would say there's not
a rule of thumb.
But something that does guide
us in the release of code is
that there's some things
that are just very
difficult to release.
So it would have been
very difficult--
we thought about releasing
our MapReduce software.
We really thought deeply,
particularly when Hadoop was
coming out.
But it was so intertwined for
reasons of optimization with
the rest of our stack that it
was actually very difficult to
consider doing, so
we didn't do it.
So I would say there's
no rule of thumb.
The difference between
research and X?
Xs tended to focus on a
collection of topics that are
not things that the rest of
Google is already doing.
So that's the differentiation
between X and other innovation
that's been going
on at Google.
That's a rule of thumb.
I can't say it's hard and fast,
but that's my impression
of what the differences
are, and I think
it's generally right.
Last question here that I had
is does research develop end
user products or prototypes?
And the answer is yes.
OK, now we can take the
two questions if
we want back there.
We do both.
Go ahead.
You need to find a mic.
I didn't mean to dismiss
the two folks that
had stood so long.
I apologize for that.
AUDIENCE: Name's Frank
from Florida.
We've come so far in the
last 5, 10 years.
What's your thoughts on where
we'll 10 years from now in
this industry?
What do you see computer
software doing?
In 30 seconds each, guys.
JEFF DEAN: I think we're
making real progress on
perceptual problems.
So things like speech
recognition and vision are
showing dramatic improvements
over the last few years, and I
think that's going to continue,
because we sort of
have a handle on what the right
approaches are, and we
just need to scale them up and
make them work better.
And that's really going to
change a lot in terms of how
you interact with the computers
or computing devices.
I think they're going to kind
of vanish into much smaller
devices that you carry around,
and aren't big full size
laptops that you
interact with.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Peter.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah, I would
agree with that.
I think we're getting
more contextualized.
A computer is not something
that you go to to use.
It's something that's around you
all the time, and sort of
more integrated into your life,
rather than being a
separate thing.
THAD STARNER: OK, I'll play
the mad scientist.
I believe that we are currently
living in the
singularity, to borrow
[INAUDIBLE]
term, and I believe that we'll
see that where the tool stops
and the mind begins will
start becoming blurry.
We'll be able to start thinking
with our tools in new
ways we haven't been able
to think before.
ALFRED SPECTOR: OK, last
question I think
I can take in blue.
I'm sorry.
We'll be happy to answer
the next one
privately after the talk.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So we've seen some
recent announcements on
Google's involvement with
quantum computing, and I'd be
interested to hear the viewpoint
on the classes of
algorithms, the problems that
can solved, and the usefulness
of that at Google
in the future.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Well, so I
think no one really knows
exactly where all this
is going to go.
I don't think we truly know, but
it's gotten to the point
where it definitely may very
well be interesting.
There may be classes of programs
that this D-Wave
architecture actually is
plausibly good at solving
relating to, say, image
and such things.
So we're trying to learn.
We're trying to also
push the future.
We want to contribute not just
the technologies that are ripe
for harvesting tomorrow, but
in some cases, for the ones
that will be important
in the longer term.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah, I think it's
still pretty early.
ALFRED SPECTOR: All right, I
guess we're going to get the
last question, because
you're--
AUDIENCE: Is there any kind of
research going on combining
Glass technology with connect
technology, where like, person
in front of you doing sign
language, and then it spits
out your language saying, like,
there's some kind of
translator in between?
THAD STARNER: I think I can't
comment on any of
those sorts of things.
ALFRED SPECTOR: We'll try
to handle it separately.
Come on up.
So look, let me just remind you
all, if you could please
fill out the form.
I don't know how to get it here
for you, but if you go
and do something here, you
can find the form.
Why don't you get that here?
And we thank you for coming.
There's going to be big
changes in education.
Stay around and hear
about that.
That's my two cents.
Thanks, guys.